[Music]
our minority rights in India under
threat in a country known for pluralism
India's secularists face their biggest
challenge yet vigilante attacks on
Muslims have shocked many Indians a
firebrand Hindu cleric with a published
private militia now runs India's largest
state on social media and TV Hindu
culture warriors promote hardline
identity politics
India's ruling Bharatiya janta party
bears some of the blame for this new
extremism but there's also something
deeper going on simply put the model of
Indian secularism has failed tip toeing
around religious sensitivities India led
different religions implement their own
personal laws rather than have one law
for all this meant customs like polygamy
or divorce by decree are legal for
Muslims but not for Christians or Hindus
championing group rights over individual
rights and tolerating regressive
religious practices bred Hindu
resentment Indian secularists are right
to worry about a new wave of bigotry but
to fight it they need to look forward
not backward rather than go back to a
failed model that prioritized special
rights for some they should champion
equal rights for all to learn more about
my take on India check the links in the
description below also let us know what
other topics you want our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI